hey hey we are Muslim but funny you
killed the boys to us and instead
they're like this is wrong he had no
right killing them right so glad to be
back this is a weird screwy setup this
morning we're in studio live in Ann
Arbor actually with fun dip of course
fun dip Dan you can follow our wonderful
guest who does not have a Twitter let me
introduce you really quickly and then
we'll just get right to it
Rachel Jenn Kowski I get that right I
got that right who is the girl a hero
who got American sniper put back on at
University of Michigan so again we were
talking about how we hate it when hosts
just try and take over the guests so
tell us the story it's a national story
now American sniper was going to play
University of Michigan take it from the
top baby
all right so every Friday night the
University of Michigan hosts you mix
which is a time for students to be able
to come out it's an alternative to going
out and drinking on campus yeah it's a
time they have events where they host
movies they'll do open buffets anything
for students and so this particular
Friday they were going to do American
sniper as the movie unfortunately there
were a group of students who started a
petition or a letter on Tuesday and they
reached out to the Center for campus
involvement at the University of
Michigan and Center for campus
involvement is the group that puts on
this event and they said that they were
going to be offended by the movie
because yeah I've used Chris Kyle's
racist and because the movie perpetuates
negative and misleading do they actually
say he was a racist yes they did in
their letter and they said he was a mass
murderer and so the university I think
within 24 hours of receiving the letter
cancelled the movie and they said that
because people were going to be offended
and disturbed by it that they were going
to not show it and instead they were
gonna show Paddington Bear and so at
that point by the way nothing against
Paddington Bear but I think he hates
America
I thought it was actually a pretty funny
move on the part of the University of
Michigan and we couldn't handle the
emotions of American snipers so instead
we're gonna go with Paddington Bear a PG
movie so like a number of people I was
pretty upset when I heard about it
and I wanted to turn that anger into
turn into action so use that passion for
actually something good so I started a
petition and I went into the Center for
campus involvement and I asked them if
they would reinstate the movie and they
said they would not and I told them that
I'd be back later and I'd have at least
300 signatures because that was what was
on the original letter from this group
who was opposed to the movie and this
group who was opposed to the movie was
it was a Muslim group or was it led by
it was led by the Muslim Students
Association of Muslims here's my point
here okay now it would seem to me that
if you're a Muslim
you would want to distance yourself from
the terrorists that Chris Kyle killed
yeah exactly like you should be going
yeah yeah and instead they're like this
is wrong he had no right killing them
right you would think they'd want to
distance themselves from Isis or myself
from al-qaeda groups like that terrorist
groups and denounce them and say that
that these groups are actually spinning
their religion and making it into
something that it's not and instead
they're denouncing people like American
soldiers like Chris Kyle who have fought
for their right to even be able to
petition the student government and to
petition the center of the center for
campus involvement and it's it's pretty
scary when you think about it oh yeah
well what's crazy is like you said it
was led by a Muslim but I'm sure a lot
of people who signed on weren't Muslim
and under Muslim Muslim countries those
people their opinion would mean nothing
they don't get to sign on under Sharia
law okay I'm gonna sign this petition go
away go away you converted you're lucky
we don't kill you sorry listen I am the
one who is horrible a discriminatory not
our lovely guest Rachel Jankowski so you
and then unrelated that the U of M
football coach is obviously this major
celebrity said we're going to be
watching it anyway they did an
about-face now they're showing both but
a big part of that was you got those 300
signatures how hard was it for you to
get those signatures on cam oh
absolutely not at all so we started the
petition a group of students around I
think 10 in the morning we had 300
signatures within the first few hours we
got up to almost 600 signatures and that
was by the time that coach Harbaugh came
out and said that he would be showing
American sniper to the football team and
he's proud to be an American he's proud
of Chris Kyle and
if you don't like it and so be it I
think at that point now we actually
never reached out to him he took it upon
himself to you know make a statement on
this issue and at that point I think
that's when the university realized they
really screwed up and I was actually
pretty impressed with the university
because they came out and admitted that
they made a mistake they apologized for
it and they reinstate the movie so I was
pretty happy with that that is pretty
sweet yeah and actually have you seen
American sniper yeah of course it's a
great movie except for the fake baby you
cannot get around now on it like why do
they just like there it seems like last
minute the script supervisor was going
crap fake baby just got a cabbage got
money you know everything about Clint
Eastwood is he bring what he does better
than anyone as he brings out great
performances yes he does and that's
because he's an as an actor you know
that's how I started one take I mean I
was on a film set one time where the guy
would do 15 takes because his background
was director of photography and so for
them he's looking at the focus of the
lens right and he doesn't even care
what's going on with the actors and so
like I had a scene where I had to cry
and were supposed to be very emotional
and by the time you look at the film
it's it's not it's not that scene
anymore because he can't do it more than
why anyway off track so this is
happening on University right now you're
is it is it okay me sort of outing you
as you lean to the right oh yeah that
would be correct okay I don't want to
know I mean it's pretty obvious I think
how hard is it for you to be on a campus
like U of M um so I went to the
University for undergrad as well as for
law school I'm in my second year of law
school at the University of Michigan so
it's been 16 holter did to it you yes
she did so this is my sixth year at the
University I've been pretty active in
politics since I was here I was the
college Republican president a couple
years ago I've been involved with young
Americans for freedom for that amount of
time as well and so it's difficult I'm
not gonna lie but it's wonderful when we
have the university community and the
alumni community who is just
astronomical in size and they come out
and they support groups like us the
outpouring of support that the alumni
community have given us especially
during this petition has just been
unbelievable and so when we have all
these alumni coming in calling the
university telling them they're not
gonna donate another dime because they
cannot believe there
kind of stuff it's been amazing but it's
generally probably more alumni than
professors definitely so professors
especially during the undergraduate
program are much more left-leaning
they're very intolerant of anything
that's outspoken and do you ever do you
ever fear I know I did but I was I was
also in Montreal you know which is a
socialist province so it's as expected
you know we don't have conservatives we
have liberals and we have liberal
separatists so this was my case but do
you ever fear speaking up for for your
grades see um so an undergrad that was
definitely a thing I know for sure I've
been my grades I'm definitely taking a
hit because of it right maybe not so
much in law school I mean law school
it's a lot different in terms of the
ability to speak out but in undergrad I
think it's pretty common at the
University of Michigan and at other
public universities for students not to
be able to say what they want to say for
instance I'm sure you've heard of this
story about professor and Dean student
Doug Susan Douglas she wrote the I hate
Republicans right column and so right
and so I think it's hard for kids to be
able to speak out in a class like that
or express anything that might be out of
line with her opinion because they're so
worried about what's gonna happen with
their grades it's happened to me I know
for sure I've taken a hit and it's
really unfortunate that people have been
stifled they're not allowed to speak out
in an academic setting where you're
supposed to be hearing differences of
opinion you're supposed to be educating
yourself on these issues but you can't
actually at both sides of the story and
it's extremely well there you go Rick
I'm John Kowski was born a poor black
woman we will be back on louder with
Crowder after this break which fun dip
is not even ready for because we wanted
to be able to wrap this up in a nice bow
for us and we'll be seeing you out there
tonight at the showing Rachel Gentile
ski ladder with trotter world exclusive
exclusive we're back with our wonderful
lovely guest Rachel gen Kowski the hero
who got American sniper back on the U of
M campus she's nodding her head no I'm
not trying this false humility I'm not
the real hero is Chris Kyle don't call
me what's always funny is when nobody
you know someone comes in and goes don't
call me a hero folks and you're like
clearly nobody did
one that does that every morning walks
in do not call me a hero leave order me
a hero
order me a hero so Rachel you feel like
you seem like you've done this before he
doesn't want a raise I've been on the
radio a few times there's been a lot of
controversy at University of Michigan so
this is true and they don't like me
there I'm not surprised they don't like
me Tom now we actually had one guy last
video we did the free speech video tried
to complain that he was going to get it
removed from YouTube because he didn't
like the in it what's funny is it was in
the free speech video yeah and it was
the guy who was actually reasonable who
was like I don't think these kids do
their research and they don't know what
they're talking about and these words
don't seem offensive to me so like we
never honestly we ended all videos right
but we don't edit people who are
conservative to look liberal or liberal
to look conservative and he was like I'm
gonna have my I had my lawyer on
retainer we were like this was a public
location and you and you agreed to do it
first off even if you don't agree to do
it we can tape you and you agreed to do
it so it's it's always weird when you do
that stuff man people just complain at
university like you said they're so you
were thinking of actually what giving
out what tonight pacifiers or blankets
anything to represent terms of the
coddling of the University of Michigan
because we can't handle anything over PG
you know Paddington Bear it's good
enough I mean I don't it's gonna offer a
great dialogue come on yeah English
Bears or something well the necessity of
a raincoat would be especially here
though this rain well the acid rain
because of global warming you're right
so it's all coming back fracking let's
blame fracking I have not seen
Paddington Bear the film I have not
either
I am willing to bet fund up she can't
hear you no headphones so let's let's
let's keep your dialogue to a minimum I
love that movie get her car service to
get her back to the campus going
Paddington Bear I've never seen it okay
you can tweet me folks at s Crowder if
you have questions for Rachel I would
bet dollars to doughnuts Paddington Bear
probably has some environmental message
there might be or an anti-business
message maybe maybe but I actually just
think is the university having a good
time just saying hey look if you can't
handle it we'll just give you this PG
movie family fun entertainment go for it
do you think it was a screw you from the
University I don't know I think it's a
little funny I don't know maybe it
wasn't maybe they that's what they were
on the show but it seems a little ironic
yeah I don't know why they would pick
Pat well there is the build-a-bear thing
going on
so maybe they try to tie it into the
build-a-bear maybe not sure maybe
they're just horrendous people there's
always a possibility I mean we were
talking about this today do you feel on
campus with young liberals
I mean how will you 23 okay so we're not
actually that far and age 27 so when I
speak at young America's Foundation
which is where you you journey you do
work with them yes I used to intern for
young America's Foundation and now I'm a
part of I'm an advisor to the young
Americans for freedom right raising
Michigan okay there you go so folks
young Americans for freedom support her
work look them up and the one thing I've
noticed and you tell me for Marc does it
seem like young liberals now are so
aggressive yeah I mean especially on
University campuses I think especially
at the University of Michigan it's such
an activist campus it always has been
and so they feel like they have free
rein to do whatever they want and the
university tends to kowtow to them and
it's pretty unfortunate because that's
where the freedom of speech is stifled
and so when groups like this go out and
they say that this video shouldn't be
shown because it might be offensive
that's when it's pretty alarming and
when president schlissel the new
president at the University of Michigan
came in during his inauguration he had
talked about this he talked about how he
wanted openness for dialogue he wanted
people to actually see the other side of
things because it might actually instead
of instead of offending people it might
actually start a dialogue right and so I
was really excited when he came in as
president and so it's kind of been
disappointing to see so many these
stories come out lately that seem to
stifle freedom of speech freedom of
expression and so it was really great
that the university came out and
actually backtracked on this one I I
always say this and you can correct me
if I'm wrong I know was true for me
again being raised in a socialist
province do you feel like conservatives
because they're constantly swimming
upstream and fighting every put its way
it's really easy to be a liberal in
college right for sure it's just the
default position your professors
everything you watch all the music you
listen to do you feel like conservatives
and I know there's going to be some bias
here do you just feel like they're more
informed on the actual issues than
liberals on campus I think they have to
be informed in order to actually form an
opinion they're not going to get it
they're not gonna be indoctrinated in
the classroom right which is what
happens at these universities it's so
much liberal indoctrination
so it's very easy to kind of just fall
in with the rest of the crowd here's
something and just kind of take it as
truth which is what was so scary about
this petition going back this this
letter that they sent said Chris Kyle
was a racist and he's a mass murderer
and if you take that is true and you do
not denounce it at all it just seems
like no was this written by the Muslim
this was written by them yes and it was
sent in to the University in the
university didn't say anything against
it again that's so telling to me Chris
Kyle wasn't a racist chris kyle was anti
Islamic terrorists so for them to say
he's racist is to put all Muslims all I
guess Arabs in the same plane at the
same level as Islamic terrorists they're
basically saying we identify enough with
Islamic terrorists that it's offensive
to us that to me is kind of nutty yeah
it's a little scary so I would think
you'd want to distance yourself from
those radicals and actually denounce
them rather than people like Chris Kyle
so yeah it's pretty crazy to me I mean
I've never read anything Chris Kyle like
to tell stories you know what what
Marines are Navy SEALs don't but I've
never seen anything from him that was
weirdly racist I mean you know there are
plenty of obviously black people and is
in his divisions platoons I don't know
the exact terminology but um you have
the right to your own opinion you don't
have the right to your own facts and so
if you want to say that you can but the
universities should not be accepting
that as truth and that was what really
bothered me well this is why I say
you're a hero
and I say it kind of obviously semi
facetiously but not really because if
you didn't do this right you're lucky
you have a coach there who's got a brass
pair now probably wouldn't have happened
before this coach if you didn't do this
right the Chris Kyle's a racist we don't
want this movie being shown accepted as
fact by the University nothing would
have happened yeah I would have stayed
the same way and all students would
assume right by proxy well if the
University says endorses this letter in
statement must be true and then they go
on the rest of the life thinking Chris
Kyle's erases yeah it's not they
necessarily endorsed it it's that they
just never did anything to speak out
against it or that they never said we're
not accepting this letter is truth what
we're doing to cancel the movie for
whatever reason that they wanted to
write um and that's it's really
concerning and what really concerns me
even more is that there are a
smaller minority on this campus and it's
the veterans and they to sit there and
and kind of not say anything it makes
them feel as if they're unwelcome on
this campus we had actually have that
going and speak to the university about
it and they actually said they had never
even thought about that opinion and
that's what really bothered me because
I'm like these people went and fought
for this country for your right to to
speak for your right to show this movie
right and you don't even think about
their opinion how it might affect them
and I mean they need to be honored and
it's really unfortunate that happened it
is unfortunate and what's more
unfortunate is I mean I don't want to
say more they're equally unfortunate is
that that really is we use the word
narrative and it's often overused in
politics but that narrative is allowed
to be set if the university doesn't even
so much to say hey will acknowledge a
request to not play the film but to call
him a racist is inaccurate we need to
correct this they didn't do anything
like that and like you said you can only
have so much of that day in and day out
on a campus where that happens we're all
liberals all professors are liberals and
it can affect your grades where every
single protest is liberal where every
single film and obviously the media and
entertainment history is a liberal
before you just start taking that as
default and that's what concerns me
there really isn't another voice at the
table and if you look at the American
public how successful American sniper
was I mean there's a huge divide not
only between politicians but it seems
like academia and average America and
most of these Americans know they've
gone to college but they've moved on
they've become conservative do you
notice like let's say when you go back
home and we don't have a lot of time but
you go back to them to your family that
it's like their school life and this is
the opinion and then there's America and
its kind of divided oh absolutely I
think he harbors a little bubble and the
University of Michigan is a little
bubble and when these students go out
into the real world they're gonna be
completely shocked I don't think they're
gonna be able to handle jobs in their
life because if they're so shaken up
about a movie that they were not even
required to see if they didn't like it
they didn't have to go if they're that
bothered by it how on earth are they
gonna be able to cope in the real world
and I'm not sure they gets it's it's
scary it's scary the university is
trying to coddle these children until
they're what 22 years old and they
graduate and then throw them out in the
real world I mean they don't even want
them they wanted to stay in their
parents plan until 26 yeah that's true
there's there's a syndrome
called second adolescence where people
you know they used to go on and have
families at my age and get married yeah
and get a job get a job and now people
are just partying until you know college
for a lot of people's four years of
glorified alcoholism but now that goes
well into the 30s with people yeah so
it's it's scary and do you see that how
do you see that changing how do I see
well what could what can people do to
change it I mean I think that people
need to expose themselves to other
viewpoints and if we're honest not the
kind of exposing themselves London
subway if we are on a campus that
preaches diversity then students should
actually be exposed to diverse ideas
that's where groups like young Americans
for freedom come in they bring in
speakers like you steven crowder or they
can bring in the alternative viewpoints
so that students can actually be exposed
to something that's not what they hear
every day in class and so I think it's
gonna be hard for for people to go out
and actually do something on their own
but we're glad that we have groups like
this that alumni will support those
groups and we ask that you absolutely we
talked about that in the video on campus
they want all different kinds of
diversity except for that of
intellectual diversity Rachel Jen Kowski
we will see you later this evening thank
you so much for coming out thank you so
much do subscribe by clicking my face or
watch this previous video if you don't
you probably hate free speech and
support terrorist bears from England
he's from he's from England right
Paddington he goes to England either way
he hates America